oh boy this is bad hey everyone i'm abby
sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and thank you all so much for your
patience with this
as it was definitely a beast for me to
write but at your overwhelming request
we'll be looking at olivia d'andrea's
glow up
diaries note that at the time of filming
this
olivia has released up until season two
episode three so if i missed things at
the time
of this video's release please excuse me
um i might need to do a another
follow-up video after the fact so
just let me know below if that's
something that you want but first
i want to chat about my sponsor build
bar so you guys know i am
working my way through some of the
flavors here and i think so far
my favorite is the cookies and cream but
if you are new here and you haven't
heard me wax poetic about these bars
i love them because they actually taste
good
when let's be real most protein bars out
there
kind of taste like chalk but these ones
are like a chocolate covered
nugget meets marshmallow bar so good
kind of like a milky way or mars which
let's be real is
pretty awesome so today's little flavor
is
coconut almond which we haven't done yet
um it's legit like
those mounds chocolate bars that i used
to love as a kid
so good so this is a low sugar bar um so
if you're looking to have this
as like a post-workout snack and you
want to replenish those glycogen stores
i would definitely go and pair it with
like a banana or sweet potato or a bowl
of
oatmeal but it's been a great middle of
the afternoon snack
and also for breastfeeding fuel late at
night
and if you guys haven't tried these out
already which i know so many of you have
since you've been
sending me tons of dms with pictures of
your favorite
you know bars in your hall but
definitely let me know your favorite
flavor
below but if you haven't tried them yet
and you don't want to miss out
i'm leaving a link and a promo code for
20 off of your order
below also you can pause the screen or
look at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a
massive trigger warning to those with
current
or previous experiences with disordered
eating honestly
this was probably one of the most
triggering channels i have
ever reviewed here as there's a lot of
discussion
and actual footage of binge-like
behaviors
so if this is not supportive to you and
your journey
please sit this one out it is honestly
pretty intense also don't forget to
subscribe to this channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out also i want to draw some
attention to my description where i've
got some resources and links to a few
experts that i interviewed specifically
for this video
just to help me get some added insight
into some areas that maybe i'm not so
much an expert on
all right a super quick overview of
what's going on if you haven't seen this
glow up series
come up in your feed now olivia is a
super talented filmmaker and youtuber
who posted season one
of her series the glow up diaries back
in 2018 when she was
just 18 years old so in it she describes
a pretty tumultuous relationship with
food
which started with a desire to lose a
little bit of weight before college
and soon turn into severe restriction
and over-exercising behaviors not
surprisingly
this led to binge eating and what she
describes as
an addiction to sugar now one of the
most shocking
sentiments from the series so far that i
received
multiple dms about was olivia's comment
about
her weak mind leading to her binge
eating tendencies
oh my gosh no so she
since backpedaled in her apology video
where she said
that she wasn't calling her disordered
eating week
but that her soul was weak i'm not sure
that really makes the sentiment
okay but i do want to remind all of you
who may be struggling in your own
relationship with food this
is not your fault overeating or
not being able to lose weight is not a
result
of poor willpower or mental weakness
it's actually your body and mind being
really intelligent
when its needs have not been met and
fighting for survival with the best
tools that it has
it's actually a sign of strength and we
should be grateful to our body and mind
for fighting
so hard for us not mad that it failed or
let us down
i also want to very briefly touch on
olivia's assertion that she doesn't have
an eating disorder
but rather has disordered eating as a
result of an addiction to sugar
so i have a whole video about the
research on sugar addiction which
you can check out right here and while
the jury is out on
its legitimacy from a biophysiological
or clinical perspective
i'm not denying its possibility or
at least that the experience of food and
sugar addiction
is very real what i can tell you however
is that the media had a frenzy about
mice research
suggesting that sugar is as addictive as
cocaine
because it causes symptoms of withdrawal
now this seems to
also be the research that olivia quotes
in her i'm sorry video
right here but if you look at the
research very carefully
what it actually says is that the
subjects aka
mice only displayed addictive or
withdrawal-like behaviors
after they had been previously
restricted of sugar
in other words when you make sugar a
novelty you are going to obsess
we know that we can see that quite
plainly
and eating disorder experts agree on
this so when you're
yo-yo dieting or severely restricting
yourself in an effort to lose weight
fast
it's totally normal to have these
obsessive-like tendencies around food
i also have to express my immense
empathy for olivia
i mean i cried along with her just
watching her journey and
blaming herself anytime she would eat
something sweet
because i just feel that she had been so
let down by literally every potential
support system
around her let's just watch this clip
for a second
you're not eating right now
it doesn't matter do not making that
living
stop this don't make it please
go to bed because you can't eat this
late at night
all that freaking sugar there isn't much
there's no sugar in this
so i spoke with my colleague alyssa
rumsey
author of the new book unapologetic
eating which i will link below
and she suggested that when parents
criticize a child's food
or body even if it comes from a place of
concern
and love it often triggers a bit of a
rebellious instinct
which makes us want to do the forbidden
behavior even more
so by telling olivia not to eat the mug
cake
it may make the drive to eat it even
stronger
alyssa suggested that the best thing
that we can do as parents
is to try to stay neutral when we talk
about food and body size
avoiding any moral language like good or
bad
and instead trying to build a more open
positive eating environment at home
another colleague of mine alyssa pearson
suggested that
if you want to help without harming to
ask
open-ended questions that encourage your
friend or your family member
to open up about their experience about
food on their own terms
we don't want to get confrontational or
accusatory which
may push someone who's struggling with
their relationship with food
into defense mode or into hiding now
what i want to actually focus on in this
video however
is the heavy hitter of season two where
olivia and celebrity personal trainer
steve zim
of a tighter you fitness walk us through
a
20-minute guide that she used to lose
weight
also side note but a tighter u
has got to go down as the most
cringe-worthy
business name of all time but anyways
let's look at this piece by piece
first let's discuss steve's sentiments
on guilt around overeating
if you fall off track do not get upset
you're not a bad person that's really
important to understand
a lot of people like oh i i feel bad do
not have that relationship with food
that's horrible every time you have a
great meal
you finish your meal you move on
terrific you did something right
you feel good about yourself let's say
you didn't eat a great meal
do not feel bad about yourself that's
not what this is about
okay next meal i'm gonna do better okay
so
i wanna start by saying i think steve
probably means well
by this remark i think what he's getting
at
and this is true is that when you start
to moralize yourself
after you eat something you shouldn't
you run the risk of getting into that
shame cycle
that can often trigger a binge we often
call it the last supper mentality
oh my gosh i ate a few fries that
weren't on my plan i'm a failure i'm
stupid i'm lazy
i might as well eat all the fries and a
pint of ice cream and all the stale
chocolate at the back of the pantry from
last halloween this
binge restrict repeat cycle is all too
common
however steve is still moralizing eating
behaviors
in this statement you know if you aren't
bad for eating the cupcake you're also
not
good for eating a bowl of broccoli
either you can't expect your mind to
embrace
one side of the coin without the other
so
next let's discuss steve's demonizing
views on
sugar sugar is what causes us to gain
weight
when we eat sugar our insulin goes
through the roof
we have to cut sugar out to get the body
to change
and it sounds like an easy thing to do
but you find sugar in a lot of things
that you're eating
these are the kind of remarks that i
take
real issue with especially because he is
speaking to a young girl with severe
restrict and binge
tendencies now while there's plenty of
reasons to keep rough tabs on your
added sugar intake with the american
dietary guidelines
recommending limiting calories from
added sugars to no more than
10 percent of your daily calories each
day or
about 12 teaspoons for a 2000 calorie
diet
that does not mean completely cutting
all sugar out this statement makes
steve's earlier sentiment about not
feeling guilty for eating
certain foods feel very hollow
and contradictory if i was olivia's
dietitian
i would be handling this issue with
major kid gloves
because cutting out sugar is exactly the
kind of restrictive food rule
that could have caused olivia's sugar
binges in the first place
i also want to flag that there isn't
anything particularly magical about
sugar
that immediately causes weight gain yes
sugar is
less satiating than let's say protein or
fat so
it is more easy to over consume but
weight gain ultimately comes down to
chronically consuming
more calories than your body needs the
fact that this is one of
steve's major arguments makes the
reality that his education
is in language not dietetics
even more obvious to me next olivia
discusses the role of
insulin and a low glycemic index diet
which is promoted in steve's book
superhero nutrition
so first of all let's quickly unpack the
glycemic index
in short the glycemic index is a value
assigned to a specific food
based on how slow or how fast it
increases
our blood sugar levels now glycemic load
combines the glycemic index
of that food by its quantity or portion
size
now the theory is that consuming more
low glycemic index carbs
keeps your blood sugar levels and
therefore your insulin levels
low and that isn't untrue a review of
the literature did suggest that there
were
some weight loss and blood sugar
management benefits
for people with diabetes however whether
or not
stimulating insulin often throughout the
day is an issue for the average
person is not so clear it would
obviously make sense that following a
low gi diet for
anyone would help prevent constant peaks
and valleys in
energy levels which may lead to a
reduction in appetite and eating
this for example may explain why
drinking a lot of soda pop which is
very high gi is associated with weight
gain but other clinical investigations
of this theory have actually produced
mixed results so it's not that cut and
dry
the other limitation of this approach is
that a lot of low glycemic index foods
like almond milk for example
are not necessarily really saturating
and don't provide a lot of nutritional
value
while a lot of higher glycemic index
foods like carrots or potatoes
do in other words paying attention to
the glycemic index of
foods doesn't necessarily tell us the
whole picture when it comes to nutrition
it also doesn't account for how the
glycemic load of a food can change
often pretty dramatically when we factor
in
the other foods that it's consumed with
my advice
think more about building meals with the
hunger crushing combination that i
always talk about
fiber fat and protein rather than
obsessing over
numbers from a chart as for insulin we
do have a lot of research to suggest
that insulin
is not the magic key to weight gain or
weight
loss one huge meta-analysis found no
difference in
body fat loss rates between a low
carbohydrate and therefore a
low insulin diet and a high carbohydrate
or
high insulin diet even in a metabolic
ward studies where food intake is
tightly controlled
and energy expenditure is measured we
see
no advantage with a very low insulin or
ketogenic diet
my colleague eric williamson from
unlocked fitness and nutrition
very eloquently reminded me that we
shouldn't be obsessing over
whether or not a single food you eat
produces more insulin
than another food like that is not what
causes weight gain over time
what we should be focusing on is
maintaining a high level of
insulin sensitivity and the best way to
do that
is to move your body regularly and
consume a
nutrient-dense diet most of the time
sugar also doesn't tell us the whole
story when it comes to insulin since
protein
and fat when consumed with carbs also
can elicit an insulin response
anyways this is all super complicated
but the bottom line is is that steve's
advice
and ultimately his book is misinformed
but
let's move on to the scale and i will
just say that this part
was very emotional to watch do not worry
about
scale weight we all look at the scale we
jump on
and we think that that's the end-all
it's not the end-all
at all yes yes
yes the scale is often such an
unreliable way to evaluate weight change
which
can fluctuate easily from water and food
consumption
hormones bathroom habits etc
so i 100 agree with steve
on that we have the scale we have body
fat
and we have measurements and what we use
a scale for is to see where our starting
number is
what i use the body fat for is to see
what percentage of the scale
is actually fat pounds how much is
muscle
how much is water the measurements now
what we do with that
is we measure the body i want to look
for symmetry
oh steve you could have just stopped
while you were ahead as i've said before
i have nothing against any of these
tools as
benchmarks for measuring success if they
feel supportive to you
but for a lot of others seeing
measurements or a body fat percentage
can be as triggering as the number on
the scale
i am honestly shocked that steve didn't
flag this with olivia before
taking her on as a client considering
her history
there are so many other important ways
that a young girl like olivia should be
encouraged to track
progress like increased energy levels
decreased stress
improved digestion better sleep or
improved mood
i have nothing against aesthetic goals
but focusing solely on weight
fat and shape for anyone but especially
for someone with a history like olivia
runs a huge risk for disorderly
tendencies
you know you might look like a
supermodel but if you are tormented by
constant intrusive thoughts about body
fat percentage
and the glycemic index of a carrot you
are not living a
healthy life in my books okay moving on
let's get to steve's three keys to get
fit
and i can already tell i am not gonna
like
what he has to say there are three parts
to getting in great shape
number one weight training number two
nutrition
number three cardio why do we lift
weights the reason why we lift weights
is to build
muscle muscle burns more calories than
fat
the more lean muscle you have the more
your body is burning calories every day
just being yourself
then we go to the nutrition we want to
make sure that we are starving the fat
and feeding the muscle
what's real important about nutrition is
there's two sides to it
it's when you eat and what you eat
number one is actually when you eat if
you're not eating at the right time
your body will not burn fat for energy
and that's really important because when
we do a workout
we want to position our body to burn fat
for energy
but if we've eaten too far before or too
far
after there's a time zone when you're
supposed to eat
then we go into cardio number three the
idea this is to put you in the zone to
burn the most amount of fat in the least
amount of time
there's a lot unpack here but since i'm
not a personal trainer i am going to
focus
on the food first i want to discuss the
idea of feeding muscle
and starving fat when i spoke to my
colleague eric about this
he did suggest that this is possible but
it depends on a few things that
aren't in our control including genetics
and a few things that
are within our control that is
resistance training
protein intake and the speed at which we
lose weight
the faster and more dramatic the loss
the greater
the muscle loss risk so he suggests
aiming for
no more than one percent loss per week i
also want to comment on steve's apparent
life mantra that when you eat is more
important than
what you eat in other words he is a
die-hard intermittent fasting enthusiast
now while some research supports that
intermittent fasting can be effective
approach for weight loss the vast
majority suggests that
it's no more beneficial than just
consuming fewer calories throughout
the day as eric told me the reason that
it often
works for some people is that we're just
not so good at
making up for meals that we missed so
you often end up just consuming
fewer calories when you're restricting
the time period in which you can eat
having said that some people actually
end up gaining weight
because they eat more during their
allowed eating window
so ultimately intermittent fasting does
not work for everyone
and each individual needs to choose an
eating approach that really works best
for them personally
if snacking throughout the day keeps you
saturated and satisfied
then you should snack i also want to
mention that intermittent fasting is
never ever recommended for those with a
history of disordered eating as like i
said one of the major reasons why it
often
fails for some folks is that getting
yourself so hungry
by pushing off a meal can often result
in an
uncontrollable binge based on what i've
seen
from olivia thus far how could that
not have been flagged now while on the
topic of steve's book
i also just want to mention a few pieces
of advice that
really don't sit well with me for
example
steve encourages clients to try to delay
eating when they're hungry
by chewing gum between meals drinking
water instead of eating food
and brushing your teeth i also just have
to call him out on the hypocrisy of his
don't feel guilty sentiments when he has
a whole guiltless dessert recipe section
riddled with cheat meal references now
moving on to steve's celebrity secrets
on the three things he believes makes
celebrities look good
balancing muscle groups creating defined
lines and improving posture
i'm not going to watch this section
because it's kind of out of my area of
expertise as i'm not a personal trainer
but it's very clear to me now that
steve's priority
is aesthetics and not health which is
probably
not a very good fit for somebody like
olivia then we get into the atu mobile
clip of the video
now this little chapter is literally
just a sales pitch for atu mobile which
apparently worked because i saw on
olivia's community page
that his website crashed from traffic
after she posted this episode so that
alone lit a little fire under my ass to
post this response asap but anyways
in the section steve talks about his
philosophy for exercise where
he focuses on isolating specific muscles
rather than encouraging compound
exercises that would recruit
multiple muscles at once now again i am
not a personal trainer so this is out of
my scope but i did consult my
long time trainer and friend jeff chan
and
he told me that isolated movements are
ideal if you're already advanced in your
training and fitness
and you're able to commit a fair bit of
time to
exercise but for your average person
looking to lose weight who doesn't have
hours every day to work out
compound moves are a much better bang
for your buck
because they hit multiple muscle groups
and they can raise your heart rate at
the same time so that they can
double as some cardio now let's talk
about steve's thoughts on skipping out
on exercise
and focusing only on dieting since
muscle is so important i take bcaas to
help promote the muscle growth and
protect it
this one in specific is made in the us
and only has high quality ingredients
which is why i'm okay taking it
okay so let's talk about bcaas or
branched chain amino acids
i've seen in other videos that steve
notoriously tells
all of his trainees to take bcaas to
enhance muscle fiber however the
research here
actually does not conclusively support
this one extensive review of the
literature concluded that
bcaa supplements alone cannot support an
increased rate of muscle protein
synthesis since the availability of
other essential amino acids will become
rate limiting for any
accelerated protein synthesis that was a
lot but
hopefully you got what i mean now
because of this a few human studies have
actually reported
decreases rather than increases in
muscle protein synthesis while taking
bcaas
we also know that the three branch chain
amino acids leucine
isoleucine and valine can be obtained
pretty easily
in everything from eggs chicken fish
chickpeas lentils and brown rice
so if you're getting enough protein in
your diet in general
a supplement is generally considered
pretty unnecessary
this is also obviously the cheaper
option but also
more nutritious since food sources of
bcaas
also contain a wide range of other
nutrients
all right now let's switch gears to talk
about sleep
something i could use a little bit more
of right now
sleep is so important if you don't get
enough sleep
your body will not allow you to burn fat
sleeping is
key so if you're only getting a few
hours of sleep you're actually working
against yourself
so the deeper your sleep your body
repairs it allows it to burn fat for
energy
okay so this isn't totally untrue we do
have research linking our evening sleep
habits to weight gain
with one six-year prospective study
finding that
those who slept less than five hours or
more than nine hours a night were 35
percent and 25
more likely to gain 5 kilos over 6 years
respectively
now findings from other cross-sectional
and cohort studies
also suggest that under sleeping is
strongly
and consistently associated with
childhood obesity
the reason for this is largely related
to some hormonal shifts that occur when
we undersleep
so for example a lot of the evidence
suggests that poor sleep can reduce our
fullness hormone
leptin and increase our hunger hormone
ghrelin sleep deprivation also seems to
increase our stress hormone cortisol
impairs our hpa axis regulation and
results in
glucocorticoid overload all of which can
increase fat storage
in fact one study found that curtailing
sleep while dieting
reduced the fraction of weight loss from
fat by 55 percent
and increased the loss of fat free body
mass by 60
and as steve repeatedly points out this
is not what you want
now let's see what steve has to say
about set point theory which
is the theory that your body has a
specific weight that you want to be at
and will basically fight tooth and nail
to maintain it
a body set point that's where our body
likes to be
so let's say you're 200 pounds
20 body fat that's where your body likes
to be
to change that need to exercise
nutrition cardio we need all three the
idea is to build the muscle
burn the fat bring down the numbers
that becomes your new set point now
when you're there if you're happy with
that number
we stay right there we hold that so
steve argues that as long as you somehow
manage to hold your weight at a lower
place for long enough
then voila you establish a new set point
but the evidence actually does not
support this in fact there's a lot of
professional criticism
of the setpoint model all of which i
outline in my blog post i'll link below
i prefer to think about weight within a
alternative model called
the dual intervention theory so this
model suggests that
instead of a single set point there's
actually more of a set point
range and that fluctuating within that
setpoint range
can actually happen fairly easily
however
moving outside of that range and
maintaining it
is a lot harder this would explain why
we usually can lose that first 10 pounds
relatively easily and can also gain 10
pounds relatively easily
but losing 100 pounds and maintaining it
is a huge feat
can it be done i'm sure it can but
statistically
it's unlikely because there's a lot of
compensatory mechanisms in the body
that act as barriers so things like
metabolic declines
muscle loss hormonal shifts to increase
hunger and silence satiety hormones
reductions in subtle movement and
activity
and of course psychological changes that
often cause obsessions about
food finally let's look at this last
chapter on under eating
so i tried reducing my calorie intake a
lot today
uh to make up for yesterday and
well now i'm eating this
when you lose weight by under eating yes
you start to drop
but you're not just dropping fat you're
also dropping muscle
so remember muscle is the engine for
burning calories
so we took this big engine and now we're
making it a small engine
so you let's say you come down a few
pounds you're starting to look good you
think this is my answer
what happens is you under eat and you
under eat it gets to a point
where your body will not change anymore
because your same calories you are under
eating at
what happens is your body starts not
reacting to it the same
and now since you've eaten so much
muscle by under eating you've
cannibalized the muscle
now you have more fat percentage than
you did before and you don't have enough
muscle
now what you're eating starts to turn to
fat and you start
gaining weight again i feel like steve
is kind of missing the point yes steve's
explanation
is true as i already mentioned that our
body does adapt metabolically to being
underfed especially if we have lost
muscle
you know we've seen that very clearly in
the biggest loser research where
participants metabolism declined an
additional
500 calories on top of what would be
expected from just
living in a smaller body than they used
to but
research suggests that for average
weight losses
a slowed metabolic rate likely accounts
for far less of typical weight regain
than overeating does and what causes the
immense drive to overeat or binge
under eating which was exactly what
olivia just demonstrated when she ate
that marshmallow bar
after a day of purposeful restriction i
am
shocked that steve isn't picking up on
this
really important psychological piece of
the puzzle i want to close off
on some thoughts from olivia's season 2
episode 3 video
which at the time of filming is the last
video that she had posted
now in it she shares her strategies for
shifting her mindset to help her lose
weight
and stop binge eating describing herself
as following
the mindset of a navy seal first of all
i do think she shares a few nuggets of
advice that may be supportive to some
people
who are trying to find the motivation to
make some kind of healthy change in
their life
so things that i generally agreed with
were her suggestions to find
confidence in yourself rather than in
the approval of
other people or in your body and also
around confronting
insecurities in your life but i see a
lot of red flags in the
rules that she suggests that she lived
by to help her change
in discomfort you know you're growing
and that is the only way to be happy
because progress equals growth
growing is living living is happiness
this is one of my happiness formulas
that did indeed succeed
you've got to create these rules in your
head if this
then that here's mine if i'm doing hard
things
then i'm happy progress equals happiness
for me which means that i got to keep my
focus
focused on progress okay
no you do not need to do something hard
or overwhelmingly uncomfortable
to gain confidence or happiness in your
life speaking as a complete
type a perfectionist i can attest that
progress
does not equal happiness at least not
for me
in fact an obsession with progress and
productivity and perfection
are probably the only things in my life
that have actually stood in my way
of true happiness so i can't deny that
this may be a helpful mantra for olivia
at this moment
i think it's probably not great advice
for the masses
what i am more confident about for
olivia specifically
is that putting yourself in a constant
state of discomfort
creates another perfect storm to swing
back to old habits like this
oh i don't wanna drink this water i
think i throw up i think i'm gonna throw
up
this should not be the goal muscling
through
a workout that makes you want to throw
up only to say that you're going to do
it again because
discomfort equals growth is a great way
to condition yourself
to hate any kind of movement this is not
how healthy
long-term habits are formed this is how
we form a dysfunctional relationship
with an activity that will never provide
us with true happiness or health
and while i'm ranting here i just need
to say that
i was also a little bit turned off by
this comment right here
just remember doing hard things makes
you tough
that's what i'm going to teach my child
in the future as a mom of two boys
i really hope not i think we need more
empathetic kids
particularly young boys like her nephew
in this clip
we don't need more young men forced to
live out this
toxic masculinity narrative in 2018
the american psychological association
put out a set of guidelines for men
and boys suggesting a call to stop
parenting with a focus on the toxic
masculinity ideals of achievement
adventure
risk and the obscure of appearance of
weakness key word here is olivia's
apparent enemy
weakness the report goes on to suggest
that parenting with this ideology
limits male psychological development
constrains their behavior
results in gender role conflict and
negatively influences
mental and physical health i don't know
about you
but i don't want that for my boys and if
i had a daughter i wouldn't want that
for her
either it's okay and actually important
to allow yourself to feel sad scared
insecure and anxious and to express
discomfort pain and emotion
i get that this isn't the navy seal way
that she's describing herself as
idolizing but the research suggests that
this mentality alone
will not help support healthy happy
adults who are capable of fostering
healthy happy relationships with
themselves or others
this front does not help us heal and
grow from within
in conclusion i would say that if i can
give olivia
any advice it would be to find another
trainer
one who has a better knowledge and
sensitivity to olivia's binge restrict
history
now steve isn't necessarily wrong in all
the things that he says
but his advice and approach is just
grossly problematic for a client like
olivia
no one with a history of disordered
eating should be exercising to the point
of
nausea and following a strict low gi
intermittent fasting diet this will not
improve her health
it will only prolong olivia's journey
and true recovery
despite calling her past struggles with
food disorder eating
olivia does currently claim that she's
extremely happy
and now has a healthy relationship with
food and
obviously i can't deny that i'm not her
and i'm not her therapist but i'm
flagging this because in practice
any respected dietitian even one who
exclusively works in
aesthetic driven weight loss would never
recommend a protocol like this to a
client like olivia
and for that reason i strongly urge all
of you watching to be
critical media consumers and to be weary
of the information and suggestions
that you've seen here in this series i
know how enticing it is to see
olivia's body transformation set that
strong
empowering drum beat but i think that
this could be
really dangerous advice in the wrong
hands
so if you are struggling or have
struggled with similar challenges
as olivia please get your advice from a
healthcare provider
not a personal trainer and not a
youtuber
myself included this is not the path for
you
and on that note that is all that i have
for you today i'm going to leave some
resources below for those who've
struggled with disordered eating
and again thank you to all of my
colleagues who i interviewed to help put
this video together
also a big thank you to builtbar for
sponsoring if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with what you
want to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye